six mois sous les tirs 6 mois
d'occupation russes izioumov n'est plus
que désolation
une plaie béante à l'image de ses
habitants qui sont restés
repeindre les chars et les camions russe
pour effacer les traces de leurs
propriétaires le fameux z triste symbole
de l'opération ne suffira pas à faire
oublier
irina milhouse ne trouve plus ses
repères dans les ruines elle a passé les
six derniers mois caché chez elle
terrorisée à l'idée que les soldats
russes trouvent les affaires de son mari
il est au front elle ne sait plus où
dans l'armée ukrainienne
nous avons caché toutes ces affaires
dit-elle pour qu'ils ne les trouve pas
nous les avons enterré ils n'ont rien
trouvé avec l'armée alors rien ne nous
ont pas touché mais nous avions peur
parce qu'ils sont venus avec des armes
non strache moment
s'est terrée dans ce petit réduit au
sous sol de sa maison que caterina a
vécu l'occupation
veuve elle n'était pourtant pas seul en
mars alors que les russes venaient de
tous pays zoom son chien est venu
l'alerté en panique en le suivant dans
le potager elle a fait une découverte
choquant un homme qui l'a cru mort
gisait au pied d'un arbre
a commencé à le déshabiller il était
complètement noir dit-elle ses bras et
ses mains avaient été électrocutées son
visage était plus un de ses yeux
baignaient dans le sang ses jambes et
ses pieds étaient complètement noir
aussi ils ont dû le frapper avec des
bâtons c'était tories
katerina la soigner nourrir protéger
alors même que les soldats
patrouillaient pillet son jardin des
soins constants du prodiguer de nouveau
quand une partie du plafond s'est
affaissé à la suite de bombardements
comme des taureaux sont excédés fonderie
dit elle il est fait d'allonger la le
silence est tombé à l'extérieur nous
sommes sortis tout était en feu dehors
tout brûler et des soldats sont venus en
courant avec des mitraillettes c'était
horrible horrible au chaud
elle n'avait pas revu micha qui est
devenu un fils pour elle depuis la
libération 10 young il y une dizaine de
jours elle le retrouve aujourd'hui
toujours faible qualité chez du jour
occupe
[Rires]
micha montre comment un des soldats
tchétchènes kessy style lui a tranché la
gorge avec un couteau et pour expliquer
pourquoi il avait été emmené par les
soldats russes il montre ses papiers de
l'armée mischa faisait partie de la
défense territoriale disions nous nous
sommes gardés dans une grange raconte-il
où il y avait un gros bloc de glace
j'avais faim j'avais soif et j'ai dû
manger la glace c'est comme ça qu'il me
gardais 12e temps pendant neuf jours il
a subi différentes torture raconte micha
électrocution simulacre de noyade au
dixième jour il a été relâché dans les
bois près de la gare avec un tir dans
les airs en guise de menace je
n'arrivais pas à faire trois pas avant
de tomber dit l'homme 3 pas et je
m'effondrais je ne pouvais plus respirer
j'avais perdu beaucoup de sang
impossible de voir un médecin il doit
tout à celle qu'il appelle son âge sa
deuxième mère une inconnue qui n'a pas
hésité une seconde à tout risquer pour
le sauver
du bourg je ne serais pas ici sans elle
tout simplement je ne pouvais plus
marcher et même si j'avais pu marcher je
n'aurais jamais atteint la maison pour
une simple raison j'étais couvert de
sang je n'avais pas de papiers
d'identité et des ennemis se trouvait à
chaque coin de rue
nulle part sauf peut-être ici dans une
fosse commune découverte quand les
soldats ukrainiens ont repris la ville
disent yum c'est l'odeur qui vous prend
la gorge avant de saisir l'ampleur de ce
qui est maintenant estime tiers à ciel
ouvert des dizaines d'enquêteurs si
active entre ceux dont la lourde tâche
et de déterrer chacun des corps quelques
450 temps bruce empile parfois deux ou
trois cadavres une fosse où une
vingtaine de soldats ukrainiens ont été
retrouvées entremêle selon les autorités
ukrainiennes l'état l'âge de crimes de
tortionnaire a dénoncé le président yves
hinse qui la preuve selon la police que
des crimes de guerre ont été commis par
la russie
plusieurs corps ont été retrouvés avec
les mains attachées dans le dos avec des
cordes autour du groupe entre beaucoup
portaient les marques de blessures dans
des explosions corps qu'on sort de la
terre à des glissements loïc raser ou
des membres amputés en chine ce policier
l'objectif principal de ce travail
acharné c'est bien sûr de documenter de
possibles crimes de guerre mais tous
ceux qui ont été enterrés ici ne sont
pas nécessairement morts de façon
violente et pour les familles qui
attendent de récupérer les leurs ce sont
deux très longs moments d'angoissé
ils attendent patiemment près d'une
tente érigée dans la forêt face au
spectacle dont la désolation n'a d'égal
que la puanteur dacia a le numéro 3 104
qui marque le lieu où est enterré sa
mère est morte pendant l'occupation de
causes naturelles
si tenté qu'il est naturel de mourir
caché dans une cave pour échapper à la
violence des combats je devrais
je veux enterrer ma mère dans la dignité
dit à issia et la besoin de ça je veux
aussi confirmé que son corps et bien
enterré ici qu'il ne s'agit pas
seulement d'un numéro quand m'a donné
comme ça je pourrai venir me recueillir
sur sa tombe et partager un morceau de
pain avec elle pour le rappeler son âme
aux sports de pau mais les roms et ça
pourrait prendre des jours des semaines
chacun des corps exhumés devraient être
autopsiés pour déterminer la cause du
décès autant dire une éternité pour sûr
on est et on n est encore bien loin ici
en
mai